Traductor: Denise RQ
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
En la Edad Media,
los alquimistas trataron de llegar
a lo que parecía imposible.
Querían transformar el humilde
plomo en oro reluciente.
La historia retrata a estas personas
como viejos excéntricos,
que nunca llegaron a ver
sus sueños hechos realidad.
Pero de hecho, hoy podemos
fabricar oro en la Tierra
gracias a inventos modernos
a los que los alquimistas medievales
no tuvieron acceso durante siglos.
Para entender cómo este metal precioso
apareció antes que todo,
incrustado en nuestro planeta,
tenemos que mirar hacia
arriba en las estrellas.
El oro es extraterrestre.
En lugar de que surja de la
corteza rocosa del planeta,
en realidad fue cocinado en el espacio
y está presente en la Tierra a causa
de explosiones estelares violentas
llamadas supernovas.
Las estrellas se componen
principalmente de hidrógeno,
el elemento más simple y ligero.
La enorme presión gravitacional
causada por dicho elemento
comprime y desencadena una fusión
nuclear en el núcleo de la estrella.
Este proceso libera
energía del hidrógeno,
lo hace brillar la estrella.
Durante muchos millones de años,
la fusión convierte el hidrógeno
en elementos más pesados:
helio, carbono y oxígeno,
y quema otros elementos cada vez más
rápido hasta llegar al hierro y níquel.
Sin embargo, la fusión nuclear llegada a
este punto ya no libera suficiente energía
y la presión del núcleo se apaga.
Las capas externas
colapsan hacía el interior,
y recuperada efímeramente de esta
repentina inyección de energía,
la estrella explota
formando una supernova.
la presión externa de una estrella
en disolución es tan alta,
que los protones y los electrones
subatómicos se mezclan en el núcleo,
formando neutrones.
Los neutrones no tienen carga eléctrica
por lo que son atrapados fácilmente
por los elementos del grupo del hierro.
Las multicapturas de neutrones permiten
la formación de elementos más pesados
que una estrella en circunstancias
normales no sería capaz de formar,
desde la plata al oro,
pasando por el plomo hasta el uranio.
Frente a los millones de años necesarios
para que el hidrógeno
se transforme en helio,
la creación de los elementos
más pesados en una supernova
se producen en cuestión de segundos.
¿Pero qué pasa con el oro
después de la explosión?
La onda de choque de la
supernova en expansión
emite los restos de los elementos
a través del medio interestelar,
desencadenando un remolino de gas y polvo
que se condensa en
nuevas estrellas y planetas.
Probablemente el oro terrestre
llegó de la misma manera
antes de ser amasado en venas
por la actividad geotérmica.
Miles de millones de años más tarde,
extraemos este metal precioso
a través de la minería,
un proceso costoso compensado
por la rareza de oro.
De hecho, todo el oro
extraído en la historia
podría apilarse en solo
tres piscinas olímpicas,
aunque esto representa
una gran cantidad de masa
ya que el oro es 20 veces
más denso que el agua.
Así que, ¿podemos producir
más de este codiciado producto?
En realidad, sí.
Con la ayuda de los
aceleradores de partículas,
podemos simular reacciones
nucleares complejas, similares
a las que crearon oro en las estrellas.
Pero estas máquinas solo pueden
acrear oro átomo por átomo.
Por lo tanto, se necesitaría casi la edad
el Universo para producir un gramo,
a un costo que supera con creces
el valor actual del oro.
Así que no es una solución muy buena.
Pero si imaginamos
que ya hemos extraído todo
el oro enterrado en la Tierra,
aún quedan otros lugares
donde podríamos buscar.
Se estima que el océano esconde unas
20 millones de toneladas de oro disuelto
pero en concentraciones
extremadamente pequeñas
por lo que su recuperación
resulta muy cara de momento.
Tal vez un día, la fiebre del oro
para la explotación de la riqueza mineral
nos llevará a otros planetas
de nuestro sistema solar.
¿Y quién sabe?
Tal vez la siguiente supernova
ocurrirá lo suficientemente cerca
para colmarnos con su tesoro
y, con suerte, no destruir toda
la vida en la Tierra en el proceso.